Transcriber: NOHA. GA
المدقّق: gaith Takrity
مساء الخير
الألعاب، من الذي لا يحب الألعاب؟
الذي يحب الألعاب فليرفع يده.
ما الذي جاء في بالكم عندما قلت ألعاب؟
مونوبلي.
الأطفال يتكلمون معنا ونشارك في
نفس اللعبة،
فبالتالي نحن جالسين نبني معهم علاقة
ونقوي هذه العلاقة وبالتالي تقوى
الثقة بيننا،
ونكون نسيج اجتماعي أفضل.
الإنتاجية،
نحن نعلم بأننا نشعر بالسعادة عندما
نعمل بجد مقابل الراحة.
ونعلم بأننا مستغلين كبشر لطبيعتنا البشرية
لقدراتنا، ولرغبتنا في تحقيق الأفضل
والإنتاجية والإثمار
فنعمل عمل شاق،
واللاعبين مستعدون ليعملوا هذا العمل الشاق
حتى يصلوا لمعاني سامية وأهداف
حقيقية، إذا أعطوا العمل المناسب لهم.
كيف نستفيد من هذه المزايا؟
مثل ما ذكرت المصطلح “gamification”
أو مصطلح التلعيب
مثل ما عرفه يوكايتشو
فكما قلت عن اللعب للجميع.
عناصر التلعيب.
للتلعيب عناصر كثيرة في نموذج مكتالسيس.
ثمانية أبعاد أنا اخترت منها أهم
ثلاثة أو أكثر ثلاثة مهمة.
لكن هذه العناصر تختلف حسب طبيعة المنتج
وحسب طبيعة النشاط الذي تعتمد عليه.
العنصر الأول هو التحفيز، وهنا مثالين:
مثال محلي ومثال عالمي لشركة نايك.
كلنا نهتم بصحتنا ونسعى للاهتمام بصحتنا
ونريد ممارسة الرياضة
بس من مستعد ان يمارس المشي
اربعين دقيقة يوميا؟
يوميا!
او ان يستمر في نشاط رياضي
بشكل مستمر يوميا.
طبيعتنا بشر، نسعى دائما للأهداف قصيرة
المدى
الأهداف الطويلة المدى هذه
هناك شيْ يردنا عنها.
نايكي استغلت هذه الفرصة من خلال ساعتهم
إنهم يحفزون الناس على ممارسة الرياضة.
فأنت كلما مشيت كلما تجيك نقاط،
وبالتالي يظهر لك رسائل تحفيزية تقول
بإنك افضل من الأسبوع الماضي.
انت اليوم أدائك جيد
انت اليوم صرت في المستوى هذا
شوف اصدقائك كم رقمهم.
فاستغلوا ميزة التحفيز وعنصر التحفيز بإنهم
يحفزون المجتمع والناس على ممارسة الرياضة.
“توكلنا”
“توكلنا” طلع في له تحديث قريب، حفزوا
الناس على التبرع، وعلى الإحسان
بإضافة حاجة بسيطة جدا إلي هي
المراحل والأوسمة
تبرعت بمية ريال سوف تأخذ
وسام لونه فضي
تبرعت بألف، تبرعت بمليون.
فكلما تبرعت أكثر كلما زاد الأوسمة عندك
وشعرت أنت بشعور داخلي عندك
بأنك جالس تنجز أو جالس تأخذ مكافأة على
الشيء الذي انت عملته
بالرغم أنها صورة أضيفت داخل التطبيق.
العنصر الثاني وهو
“التأثير الاجتماعي والارتباط”
بأخذ مثال: شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي
وكيف نحن اليوم جالسين نستخدم شبكات التواصل
الاجتماعي في التأثير وفي الارتباط
“linkedin” أضافوا حركة
مع بداية ظهور linkedin
شبكة علاقاتك الاحترافية عادة يكون
التواصل فيها رسمي
فكيف يحسنون من ميزة التواصل والترابط؟
أضافوا خاصية التنبيه
إذا زميلك في العمل كمل سنة
يطلعلك رسالة تنبيه بارك لفلان
فقد أكمل سنة
أصبح له ترقية وعمل تحديث تظهر رسالة
لكل المشتركين معه أو لكل المرتبطين معه
أنه حصل على ترقية
فالكل يتشارك في المباركة والتهنئة.
بوكينج كلنا نحجز فنادق، كلنا نسافر،
عنصر من عناصر التالي التلعيب المستخدمة
في بوكينج
هو الندرة ونفاد الصبر.
لما نجي نحجز غرف دائمًا تجينا رسالة
انه يوجد عشرة والأربعين شخص في هذه اللحظة
يشوفوا هذه الغرفة وطلع باقي وحدة.
حفزني وحسسني بعنصر الندرة وإني لازم ألقط
الغرفة، وأشتريها بأسرع وقت
واحجزها في أسرع وقت.
فهذا من عناصر التلعيب قد يكون له استخدامات
أبعد واستخدامات تجارية كثير،
ولكن في الأخير هم خرجوا عن مبدأ التلعيب
واستغلوا الصفات الموجودة عند كل اللاعبين
من ناحية التحفيز ومن ناحية تحسين مشاركتهم.
طيب كيف يمكن تطبيق التلعيب
في العمل التطوعي؟
أنا اعتقد بأنه عناصر وأساليب التلعيب تزيد
من التفاعل.
فلما أعمل التحفيز واعمل تنافس بين الأعضاء
والمشاركين في العملية التطوعية.
لا شك بأن هذا العنصر سوف يساهم في زيادة
التفاعل بين أعضاء المجموعة.
كذلك راح يضيف معنى للشيء الذي يقومون به
أكثر من استشعارهم وإستدراكهم
للمعنى الحقيقي.
كذلك المتعة.
فبالإضافة إلى العطاء ستجد نفسك مستمتعًا
وأنت تعطي أكثر
وتقوم بعملك لأنك ترغب بتحقيق
الفوز الأسطوري.
“ذكرى الفوز الأسطوري”
تخيل معي جالس تعطي وتشوف نتيجة هذا العطاء
فأنت بالنسبة لك حققت هذا الفوز إلي بك.
كذلك إضافة معنى إلى المهام فكل مهام تدرج
أو تعطى لأعضاء المجموعة
يضاف لها معنى ، فبالتالي أنت تحقق هذه
المعاني السامية التي لديك.
زيادة التنافس.
لا شك بأن التنافس يحفز الأشخاص على الإبداع
والعطاء وتقديم أفضل ما لديهم.
أريد أن أقول لكم قصة بسيطة بختصر فيها
كيف تطوعت
لأزيد من وعي المجتمع
حول الألعاب و أهمية التلعيب
لبناء مجتمع أفضل
ونخدم فيها ان شاء الله.
قبل بضعة شهور كنا مشاركين في معرض،
كان لنا وجود كشركة
وجائتنا سيدة فاضلة يمكن فوق الخمسين
من عمرها
قالت “ايش تسوون؟”
قلت والله نحن نسوي ألعاب
الإجراء طبيعي، إلي جالس يعرف بالشركة
وبمجال العمل والمنتجات.
قالت لي “انتم الي تخلوا عيالنا ينتحرون؟”
?What
لا يا خالة نحنا ما نخلي العيال ينتحرون
قالت “في الواتساب شفنا واحد ولد رابط
نفسه ويبي ينتحر.”
فهنا جاءت شمعة وشرارة.
المجتمع يحتاج توعية
في صورة نمطية سيئة في رسائل سيئة
فنحتاج الى التوعية، ونقدم معلومات تساهم
على الأقل انه تبين
فائدة الألعاب واضرار الألعاب،
ودور العائلة في انها توجه اطفالها.
عملت حساب على تويتر،وهو حسابي الشخصي،
وبدأت اشارك معلومات عن الألعاب
وطبيعتها وتاريخها
وكيف تستخدم عناصر التدعيم
في أنشطة حقيقية في أنشطة تجارية
تساهم مثلا في زيادة الإنتاجية وتساهم
في تحقيق إيرادات أعلى وإلى آخره.
علم للتطوع ان العطاء ليس بالمال فقط.
علم للتطوع بأن زيادة الحصيلة العلمية هي
بأني أبحث عن معلومات أكثر
حتى أعطي هذه المعلومات.
كذلك بنيت لي شبكة معارف أكثر وأكثر وأكثر
من مختلف الدول مختلف الجنسيات
مختلف الأعراق.
تعرفت على ناس كثير، بحثت عن معلومة في أكثر
من مكان
واستفدت من خبرات وتجارب وقصص حقيقية،
وبالتالي أنا جالس أنقلها اليوم
فهذه من فوائد او نتائج التطوع.
ونتذكر دائما أن الألعاب هي وسيلة نستطيع
أن نستخدمها استخدام الممتاز
ونحقق فيها نتائج أفضل .
شكرا لكم .